By intrusion, we mean any attack
that aims to compromise the security
ghost of an organization.
For example, performing a remote
root compromise, of an email server.
Defacing a web server to
display inappropriate content.
Guessing and cracking stolen passwords.
Stealing a database containing
credit card numbers.
Reading sensitive data
without authorization.
Running a packet sniffer on
a workstation, to capture user names and
passwords on a network.
Using a permission error
on an anonymous FTP server,
to distribute pirated software and
music files.
Dialing into an unsecured modem, and
gaining internal network access.
Posing as a company executive,
calling the help desk and
resetting the executives email account.
Using a workstation without permission.